la situation depuis quelques semaines ça
milliards au québec c'est la bouffée
d'air frais que bien des québécois
attendait à compter de lundi prochain
des assouplissements entreront en
vigueur même si le couvre-feu reste en
place aujourd'hui on arrive à la
conclusion que oui on peut faire un
petit déconfinement mais il faut y aller
d'une façon très graduelle petit
déconfinement car la situation dans les
hôpitaux demeure très fragile
chaque jour qui passe quelques 700
chirurgie sont reportés j'aurais aimé ça
arriver ce soir avec plus
d'assouplissement
mais je pense à ce report responsable
partout sur le territoire
les commerces non essentiels pourront
rouvrir leurs portes y compris dans les
centres commerciaux les salons de
coiffure et les salons d'esthétique
pourront aussi reprendre leur activité
tout comme les musées et même si on
prévoit pas le retour des barrages
policiers ont re met de l'avant les
paliers d'alert régionaux l'abitibi
témiscamingue le nord du québec
le saguenay-lac-saint-jean la côte-nord
la gaspésie îles de la madeleine et le
bas-saint-laurent passe à l' orange le
couvre-feu il sera repoussé de 20h à
21h30 et salle à manger des restaurants
pourront rouvrir mais avec un maximum de
deux adultes par table ce qu'on veut
passer des repas avec multiples cellules
ce qui va être créée réservations
registre on pourra aussi recommencé à
s'entraîner au jam ou à pratiquer des
activités sportives intérieure et par
resteront fermés mais les théâtres les
cinémas pourront rouvrir à la fin du
mois pour l'instant six régions sont
concernées mais d'autres pourraient
bientôt suivre
on ne peut pas encore eu ce qu'on
appelle une stabilité la tendance et
lille off mais on ne peut être pas eu la
stabilité qui nous permet de charger on
réévaluera la situation d'ici deux
semaines
en attendant à l'échelle du québec il
sera de nouveau permis de faire des
activités extérieures avec des gens
issus d'autres bulle familiale à la
condition de ne pas dépasser 4 personnes
en zone rouge et 8 personnes en zone
orange
on veut aussi lutter contre l'isolément
et la détresse psychologique chez les
jeunes étudiants en poussant cégep et
universités à offrir des cours en
personne notre objectif c'est que les
étudiants puissent y aller au moins deux
fois par semaine dans la communauté
médicale
on se montre résigné garder tous les
commerces fermés indéfiniment n'était
pas viable il faut ré ouvrir et nous on
sait bel système de santé que ça va
créer une pression mais je pense qu'on
est dans un meilleur endroit
présentement mais déjà on s'inquiète du
très long rattrapage qu'il faudra
effectuer
on sait que le personnel ne sera pas là
pour assurer ce retour à 100% et les
listes d'attentes sont là pour rester
pour un bon bouquin les chiffres des
derniers jours sont encourageants le
nombre de nouveaux cas et le nombre
d'hospitalisations sont en baisse mais
le premier ministre appelle à la plus
grande prudence
le québec doit être prix éviter
troisième vague
comment vivent présentement certains
pays européens ici hugo lavallée radio
canada québec